for more than 40 years Donald says
my family before joining Universal
Studios I was an agent representing
Donald for almost 20 years I was asked
to give an antidote about Donald's work
but I cited instead to share a much more
personal story that is about his great
intuition exactly 21 years ago my wife
Kelly and I met him at the Regency Hotel
in New York for dinner earlier in the
evening Donald looked at Kelly and out
of nowhere he asked her if she was
pregnant
Kelly did not look pregnant she was
wearing a fitted outfit and there was no
reason to suspect she might be not to
mention what manners right mind asks a
woman are you pregnant after we assured
Donald she wasn't pregnant he went as
far as to say he was sure she was
pregnant with the boy I also told Donald
that we have three girls and he would if
we were having another child I don't
make boys three weeks later we
discovered Kelly was pregnant and
exactly eight months later our son Eli
was born on July 17th which ironically
is Donald's birthday his is a true story
I'm proud to be here recognizing
Donald's consummate artistry and
legendary contribution to the art of
cinema he's a great husband father and
grandfather
I love Donald he's an irreplaceable
friend and one of the most extraordinary
people I've ever known
congratulations Donald on this
well-deserved honor